back in 2014 we heard that a movie based  on i dosed Montreal's thief franchise  might be happening and today it sounds  like it is indeed going ahead according  to The Hollywood Reporter la-based  production company straight up films has  acquired the rights to make the movie  the film will be produced by Roy Lee who  produced the departed and hitman agent  47 Adrian esperia the pair recently  teased a movie based on a square enix  franchise at the dice summit the  screenplays being penned by Adam Mason  and Simon boys who wrote the screenplays  for films like misconduct and not safe  for work much like the game the film  will be set in a quote dark fantasy  world where a master thief tries to  restore freedom which has been denied by  a magic wielding pirate there are no  details on the cast director or release  date as yet well let you know when more  details drop about the film so be sure  to check back on gamespot